[Musik]
hier in köln porz versuchen sie
kommunikationsdefizite aufzufangen
missverständnisse aufzuklären
jeden dienstag organisieren tanja
schmiede und sabine d kant zusammen mit
ehrenamtlichen und einem arzt eine
impfaktion mitten in der stadt
[Musik]
unterstützt werden sie von
wohlfahrtsorganisationen und der stadt
köln
ihr ziel viele menschen möglichst
unkompliziert impfen und aufklärung
und immer wieder das problem
informationen kommen nicht an oder
werden nicht verstanden ein beispiel
wenn sich die vorgaben für die
impfstoffe ändern dann müssen sabine d
kommt und ihr team diese immer wieder
erklären
die entwicklung hat einfach gezeigt dass
der schutz von johnson & johnson
das ist keine booster impfung
3,6 millionen deutsche haben sich mit
dem impfstoff von johnson & johnson
impfen lassen
anfangs hieß es für einen vollständigen
schutz bräuchte man mit diesem impfstoff
nur eine info
mitte januar ändern bund und länder die
korona schutzmaßnahmen jetzt wird eine
zweitimpfung gefordert und zusätzlich
noch ein booster von heute auf morgen
ändert sich also der impfstatus von
millionen deutschen
das macht zwar gesundheitlich sind es
wird nur nicht gut genug und auch nicht
rechtzeitig kommuniziert
ein anderes beispiel im herbst 2021
heißt es jeder solle sich boostern
lassen und zwar schnellstmöglich
doch dann deckelt der damalige
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
plötzlich den bei den deutschen so
beliebten biontech impfstoff und will
stattdessen vermehrt moderne einsetzen
die verunsicherung ist groß impftermine
verfallen weil viele menschen biontech
mehr vertrauen als moderner
die booster kampagne gerät ins stocken
und der damalige gesundheitsminister in
erklärungsnot
das hätten wir klarer noch kommunizieren
müssen aber wir haben eben mit moderner
eine gute genauso wirksame alternative
als problem ist die arztpraxen hatten
sich jetzt auf biontech umgestellt und
ich bedaure zutiefst auch die große
stress in der umstellung jetzt der in
den praxen für die teams dort entsteht
durch solche kommunikationsfehler
verspielt die politik immer mehr
vertrauen das a und o einer
langfristigen pandemie bekämpfung ist
dass die bevölkerung weiß was geschieht
so dass sie mitmacht da haben wir große
fehler gemacht und das ist auch der
grund warum deutschland heute eines der
zentren der impfverweigerer ist kaum
einem anderen land der welt gibt es so
viele eben verweigere
für zusätzliche verwirrung sorgt anfang
dezember 2021 thomas mertens der
vorsitzende der ständigen impfkommission
stiko
während die ersten länder wie israel und
die usa schon kinder impfen warten
eltern in deutschland gespannt auf eine
entscheidung der stiko
und dann sagt mertens in einem interview
auf die frage ob er sein 7 oder 8
jähriges kind impfen lassen würde also
ich würde es wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht
impfen lassen aus setzt sich als
konsequenz aus alledem was geäußertes
dass ausgerechnet der chef der
impfkommission mit so einer aussage
vorprescht sorgt für einen großen
aufschrei das chaos ist perfekt
ich war mir nicht klar darüber dass das
so ein
wirbel geben würde
wie wichtig klare eindeutige
kommunikation gerade in einer krise ist
scheint bei den verantwortlichen noch
immer nicht angekommen zu sein
als die stiko
1972 gegründet wurde war eine pandemie
weit weg noch heute arbeiten alle 18
mitglieder ehrenamtlich
reicht das für eine solche krise oder
müssten wir nicht was die institutionen
angeht ganz anders aufgestellt sein
das sind leute die haben eigentlich in
ganz normalen beruf die gehen auch
anderen tätigkeit nacht schon allein
daran sieht man glaube ich dass man
einfach das gewicht nicht wirklich rein
liegt dass diese art der krise doch
unbedingt bedürften auch die politik
zweifelt an der stiko ich glaube einfach
dass das sehr wichtige instrument der
ständigen impfkommission keines ist für
pandemie zeiten ich glaube dass man die
stücke auf jeden fall brauchen auch in
krisenzeiten ich glaube dass eine
stärkung dieser struktur sehr gut wäre
damit man noch schneller und noch
effektiver arbeiten kann
aber der damalige gesundheitsminister
ändert nichts warum wir würden gerne ein
interview mit jens spahn führen zu der
frage warum er die stiko nicht personell
besser aufgestellt hat will er nichts
sagen auch zu allen anderen fragen von
uns äußert er sich weder mündlich noch
schriftlich
in der krise lässt sich die politik von
führenden wissenschaftlern beraten doch
wie gut funktioniert dass
ein beispiel anfang november 2021
erreicht die inzidenz in deutschland
neue rekordwerte
schon im sommer hatten wissenschaftler
wie christian drosten und auch das
robert koch institut vor der nächsten
welle gewarnt
trotzdem wollen führende politiker in
der vierten welle von nichts gewusst
haben wir zeigen melanie bringt man eine
aussage von markus söder schauen sie
sich sehr beeindruckt dass nahezu alle
virologen epidemiologen und
wissenschaftler auf die wirkung dieser
neuen welle ihrer wucht und
geschwindigkeit nicht richtig
eingeschätzt
tja da kann man eigentlich auch kurz und
knapp sagen man fragt sich wem er
zugehört aber
den ganzen sommer lang wurden die
expertise und die warnungen der
virologen in den wind geschlagen auch
den präsidenten des
robert-koch-instituts platz in einer
pressekonferenz der kragen
das robert-koch-institut hat jede dieser
vier wellen rechtzeitig voraus jede
dieser vier wellen wie oft hab ich hier
gesessen und habe das immer wieder
gesagt
wieso hat die große koalition nicht
früher reagiert
helge braun war chef des kanzleramtes
und minister für außergewöhnliche
aufgaben er hat die korona politik der
bundesregierung maßgeblich mitbestimmt
die frage ist ist die politik bereit das
was die experten empfehlen umzusetzen
oder gibt es und sein dort wieder
stellen und am ende ist politik immer
ein kompromiss
natürlich ist politik kompromiss aber
die frage wie sich politik zur
wissenschaft verhält ist in einer
pandemie ganz entscheidend
[Musik]
karl rudolf korte ist
politikwissenschaftler und wahlforscher
er hat in den vergangenen beiden jahren
die pandemie politik beobachtet und
analysiert
demokratie lebt auch dadurch dass wir
nicht nur kraft wissens entscheidungen
fällen das wäre eine reine technokratie
aber politik muss sich
legitimieren für die entscheidung die
sie trifft und kein geologe muss sich
dafür rechtfertigen
melanie brinkmann kritisiert dass die
warnungen der wissenschaft vor allem in
zeiten der entspannung nicht gehört
wurden
politikberatung gab es die ganze partie
über die war aber nicht sehr
organisiert sondern es war eher ad hoc
ist es wichtig eine gewisse kontinuität
zu haben dass man beratung nicht
einstellt wenn zahlen gerade sich
entspannen
die neue bundesregierung führte mit
ihrem amtsantritt einen festen
expertenrat ein
melanie brinkmann gehört dazu hat sich
seitdem die kommunikation zwischen
politik und wissenschaft verbessert seit
es den expertenrat gibt takt dieser rat
einmal wöchentlich mit
vertretern der politik und
diskutiert auch sehr sehr offen sehr
intensiv und ich halte das für eine gute
institution und da werden wir jetzt mal
sehen wie sich das entwickelt
martin voss gehen die veränderungen
nicht weit genug der forscher an der
freien universität berlin beschäftigt
sich mit den strukturen des politischen
krisenmanagements in deutschland
tatsächlich haben wir meines erachtens
kein adäquates arrangement zur
bewältigung komplexerer krisen in
deutschland und weil das fehlt lösen wir
das dann mit ad hoc arrangement also mit
einem expertenrat
stattdessen wünscht sich der
krisenforscher dahin von der politik
unabhängiges ständiges kompetenzzentrum
dass man akteure aus der gesamten
gesellschaft der forschung den
wissenschaften aber auch aus
zivilgesellschaftlichen organisationen
strukturiert hat zusammenbringt in einem
prozess so dass sie gemeinsam
durchspielen was könnte wohl auf einen
zukommen und nicht nur in bezug auf eine
pandemie sondern auch auf andere
komplexe aber krisenszenarien
mit karl lauterbach ist nun ein
mediziner gesundheitsminister
viele setzen große hoffnungen in ihn
endlich einer der wissenschaft versteht
doch ändert sich wirklich etwas
mitte januar von einem tag auf den
anderen verkürzt das lka den corona
genesenen status statt sechs monate ist
dieser plötzlich nur noch drei monate
gültig der gesundheitsminister ist
selbst überrascht diese diskussion da
dachte ich die wir noch nicht
abgeschlossen dass sie das später
entscheiden werden und das ist aber dann
offenbar also auch an diesem abend auch
an diesem abend entschieden worden und
das ist eine also
kommunikations fehlleistung gewesen
anfang februar
2022 ändert das lka die angaben auf der
website erneut jetzt gilt der genesenen
status wieder für sechs monate
allerdings nur wenn man zusätzlich
geimpft ist das regelchaos geht auch
unter der neuen regierung weiter ich
habe kaum noch durch blicke kaum noch
niemand weiß wirklich genau was jetzt
die regeln sind und ja da aber ein
bisschen
also jeden tag etwas anderes gibt es
irgendwelche ausnahmen und dann ist die
große frage ob die was wollen sie
eigentlich
krisenpolitik bedeutet auch nach zwei
jahren statt langfristiger lösungen mit
hilfe der wissenschaft ständig ad hoc
entscheidungen viele fürchten in der
nächsten welle geht es genauso weiter
deutschland hat einen regelkatalog der
sich ständig ändert und von bundesland
zu bundesland unterschiedlich ist
wenn sie in hamburg in einem ic 1
stiegen um nach münchen zu fahren gelten
andere regeln als wenn sie kassel
ausgestiegen wären wie soll ein normaler
bürger das verstehen warum die
bekämpfung des virus in
schleswig-holstein anders soll als im
angrenzenden mecklenburg vorpommern ist
mir völlig schleierhaft außer dass ich
weiß dass in einem land die cdu dem
anderen land die spd regiert frank
ulrich montgomery ist vorsitzender des
welt ärzte bundes in einer pandemie
braucht es bundeseinheitliche regeln
findet er stößt das föderale system in
einer solchen krise an seine grenzen
auf die frage wer in zukunft die
grundregeln für corona festlegen soll
sagen 70 prozent der deutschen der bund
25% die bundesländer und 5 prozent weiß
nicht
das föderale system heißt ja nicht dass
man nicht aber an unterschiedliche
aussagen ausgangslagen hat nicht auch
unterschiedlich handeln kann also wenn
die inzidenz in sachsen 900 ist muss die
in bremen nur 50 dann müssen die
unterschiedliche maßnahmen machen nur
was sie bei der jeweiligen institute
machen das muss bundeseinheitlich sein
doch nicht nur unser föderales system
hemmt die pandemie bekämpfung im sommer
2021 ist bundestagswahlkampf der kampf
gegen korona wird scheinbar nebensache
man möchte natürlich zumutung frei durch
diese wahl monate kommen das ist ja bei
allen parteien gewesen die zumutung
freiheit zwar maximal
im wahlkampf sommer sind die inzidenz
noch niedrig doch führende
wissenschaftler und das rk ii waren
wegen der niedrigen impfquote vor einer
vierten welle im herbst für die
wahlkämpfer ist corona ein problem von
morgen
wenn wir dann im herbst sehen die im
sport ist immer noch viel zu niedrig
finde ich muss man dann weiter
nachdenken aber nicht jetzt es war
einfach insgesamt ein mann wartet ab man
reagiert bloß nicht zu früh und nicht
irgendwie oder da wieder stimmen zu
verprellen
das dilemma in wahlkämpfen wenn es knapp
wird ist ja immer dass politiker dazu
neigen dann den menschen die angebote zu
machen die diese menschen hören wollen
wir werden keinen neuen lockdown haben
und wir können die kinder die schüler
mitschüler auch wieder im
präsenzunterricht in den schulen haben
getroffen den frieden date so schnell
wie möglich bei die menschen
mittlerweile mental am ende sind hdmi
bekämpfen hat aber nichts mit angeboten
zu tun sondern mit einschränkungen die
politik scheut konkrete vorbereitungen
auf eine neue welle
man hat das bild souverän in schach
gehalten und uns möglichst in zuversicht
positioniert und das galt natürlich auch
für die pandemie dass man
gerne positiv botschaft überbringt weil
der überbringer dieser positiven
botschaft damit rechnet dass am ende
auch mehr gewählt wird als derjenige der
sagt es wird schwer stellt euch auf
schwierige monate zusätzlich ein das
problem nach der bundestagswahl ist vor
der nächsten landtagswahl
unterminiert natürlich eine art
strukturierte
krisenpolitik die auf langfristige
prozesse angelegt sein muss
dezember 2021 bundestag und bundesrat
beschließen eine impfpflicht für das
gesundheits- und pflegepersonal
februar 2022 bayern schert aus der
gemeinsamen linie aus markus söder will
den beschluss vorerst nicht umsetzen
wird die landtagswahl 2023 schon ihre
schatten voraus
gemeinsam durch die krise dieses
versprechen scheitert immer wieder an
alleingängen und politischen
machtkämpfen
zwei jahre corona zwei jahre dauer
belastung schlingerkurs aus und ups nach
den ersten wellen sollte vieles besser
werden
doch das corona chaos blieb ein
effektives krisenmanagement gibt es auch
nach zwei jahren pandemie noch nicht
in der pandemie hatte auch die chance
stecken können dinge endlich anzupacken
das land zu modernisieren auf nächste
krisen besser vorzubereiten
passiert ist zu wenig
unser selbstverständnis von tatkräftigen
gut strukturierten belastbaren land hat
gelitten
[Musik]